olá a todos pessoal daqui que falou dar
que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que five night at
freddy's 2 e hoje nós estamos cara
quarta noite sol quarta à noite a
segunda noite já foi difícil
a terceira foi muito difícil agora
imagine a quarta imaginei quinta que vem
a seguir meu ok ok só vamos garoto calmo
eu tocava eu juro que tom calmo juro o
que aí você já tem o palhaço lá isso o
palhaço eu acho que tá cada vez mais
rápido com este tempo meu tá muito
rápido palhaço
ok nada aqui está tudo tranquilo o certo
palazón hillsong ficava - é do banco é o
clube já começa meu à meia-noite e
começam um ok é o sérgio após calma da
questão se arrasta ao site rock eu vou
tentar usar a mesma estratégicos ainda
na noite de hoje à noite três aliás eu
vou usar essa estratégia em todos os
vídeos são todos os vídeos não em todas
as noites porque está a resultar está
resultado e não vou estar tanto na hora
eu não disse nada afinal vamos estar
amigo chegou a testar vocês um gol já
está em são bons ou o que eu saí calma
serra fez comigo é o mal é o palhaço aí
agora é a hora agora é de bom tom que o
país conta com isso embora não eu não
vou embora meu
ela pede para falar a sós para pagar são
paulo
todas as roupas íntimas o que tem que
fazer agora
o gato eu vou morrer aqui né
é por sermos erra puros meu só usei do
qual nunca tinha percebido que a frente
meu está a ser complicado e não tive
muita tentar sair do palhaço eu confesso
eu tenho que ficar mais detentos questão
que é o céu do palácio trama sempre anda
lá tentar sempre tirar a corda
o carlos tudo bem é que também está tudo
bem eu sei que vamos aparecer o início
por isso eu tenho aqui atenção ao meio
aqui está tudo tranquilo aplicada por um
logo da raposa já aqui mas agora está
tudo tranqüilo e o palhaço ser muito
rápido agora meu eu agora tenho que ter
muita atenção mesmo o palhaço e aí não
precisa fazer aqui exatamente calma lá
na palavra não posso esquecer ti ou não
sendo tranquilo tranquilo só vocês já
sabem se vão calar por algum instante é
porque o mesmo concentrada que os garis
twitter mesmo passar esta quarta à noite
por isso é tão estranho isso ficará
algum tempo calado assim ok é tudo
tranqüilo é que eu sei lá
o ok do balanço lá eu não sei como é que
consegue evitar o pessoal eu nunca tinha
acontecido antes
ok já não que junte 2 calma calma calma
calma calma para ficar uma palhaça ela
está tudo bem tudo bem calma anda
palhaço isso ou o serra posou cheio lá
meu
calma calma calma lá isso quando vemos a
calma
tá tranquilo pois embora fosse embora
mas alguém estava em relação ao mesmo
tempo ter relação com ela a ataque tudo
aquilo o ok ok era souza raposa já
parceira lei calma marcar uma data tem
que controlar bem os lusos já tem flash
lite 2-1 eu estava muito rápido agora
flash lite o palhaço tem esquecido pagar
pois vai aparecer como estava recebeu o
ok ok então não anda lá não aparecem lá
isso anda rápido ok aqui tranquilo aqui
tudo tranquilo pistolas eles têm muita
opção
tem muita pressão pessoal é muita
pressão em cima de mim são muitos
animatronics aparecer ao mesmo tempo eu
calma palhaço calma palhaço calma
palhaço um guga não posso perder um
carrinho de tentar atrapalhar seu
parecer model look 2 da raposa mil do im
o caraças ficamos com dez parece calma
calma calma contigo palhaço calma
contigo a questão da manhã pessoal
somente momentos da manhã estão a
aguentar bem eu dou sentir muita pressão
já em relação à terceira noite é verdade
que ela é terceira noite em relação a
esta foi muito fácil
ok ok tudo bem só são três da manhã já
possamos juntar da noite temos quase
conseguir só eu vou tentar manter a
mesma estratégia que é controlar o
palhaço e ficar sempre atenta às luzes
ok ok o o olho na obra de manoel
agora é buscar uma palhaça lá calma
vamos saltar em cima né
vamos saltar em cima não caiu estou
tranquilo só está lá em cima me faz
voltar lá em cima de mim eu não sei se é
um baita cara eu não sei até quando não
faz mal
ai ai ai está a chamar por mim mel a
campanha parece parece parece prestes a
itapevi
é que o fred está que o frente-a-frente
precisa colocar placas e da copagaz 13
amanhã o tatu se recusou a sair
rockferry fred fred acorda palestra
falando que o pa to aos opositores ao
mesmo tempo meu
calma calma calma calma calma calma aí
qualquer freio de ser feito em palha
espalhados pelas palavras palavras
palavras palavras palavras palavras bem
pessoal o que assusta é habituado a isto
vai ter um busto que o meu cérebro
estava mesmo boed ter pêlos do fight
night at freddy's eu não sei se já à
venda já esse merchandising da venda mas
se não existe ou não perder muito
dinheiro porque eu comprava eu comprava
estudo os tem que vir a idéia de se
instalar no coisas a venda de gás isso
eu não posso perder nenhuma oportunidade
de dar corda ao palhaço porque qualquer
momento vai estragar o jogo são duas da
manhã e só deu macaca conseguiu aguentar
até às três da manhã
se o curso que passar agora das três da
manhã é porque eu tô evoluir e se eu tô
evoluir é porque em algum momento vou
conseguir passar esta noite
ok eu o li este tema ainda não tinha
aparecido ela viaja por cima pouco mas
era muito perto de mim mesmo
vamos acordar o palhaço é o cloud
tranqüilo o palhaço é palhaço é palhaço
é palhaço é palhaço é palhaço é palhaço
há ainda nenhuma vinculação outra vez o
ou não zé raposas
o segundo gol não tardou a sair
eu devo andar ali perto e foi embora né
ok eu acho que sim tranqüilo o utah que
os raposas
eu não podia ter feito aquilo não eu já
sei quando eu estava em cima não posso
ir à câmara é meu não posso ser difícil
sinto a manhã eu sei que os seus
parceiros
passei quatro noites e 40 noites e 40
noites e quarta noite pra sair pra sair
pensei quarta noite pessoal
eu nem acredito não acredito não
acredito no meu coração está batendo
muito porque está passado
[Música]
quem está aqui à minha frente meu acerto
pessoal a ser o primeiro o coração tá
bater muito se fala sério esta quarta à
noite é um palhaço já viu o pai nosso e
escrever lula já tinha nos fones não é
porto não vai estar amanhã os alunos têm
muito para tentar passar da quarta no
entanto lá é que nem vinha atrás de mim
quinta à noite o maior foco gogo's fui
quarto muito que ainda nem acredito só
mas vamos ficar porque com isso fagner 7
fredes dois finalmente conseguimos
passar da quarta à noite e já tinha
tentado ontem tentei hoje consegui e vou
tentar também julgar hoje a quinta noite
se conseguir passar ainda hoje eu coloco
um vídeo de fábio neves e fred diz
mas é essencial antes carlos zorrinho
quero dizer que é dizer para vocês
passarem por um canal de um amigo meu
que é o bambu play eu faço esse terror e
coisas macabras coisas muito loucas
mesmo é eu faço vídeos sobre anjos
moniz faz tempo que os vídeos de cinco
coisas mais bizarras cinco coisas mais
isto e aquilo ser é um canal muito bom
principalmente por lá pessoal deixando o
vosso apoio é e comentem este borre
cueca pra ambos saber que vocês verão de
minha parte e é isso que só passem por
lá deixando o apoio fiquem bem e até a
próxima
[Música]